president Trump delivering on another
one of his campaign promises calling for
tougher immigration laws the president
hosted a roundtable with police
congressman and local leaders on Long
Island New York
an area hit hard by the murderous ms-13
gang we're here today to discuss the
Menace of ms-13 it's a menace they
exploited the loopholes in our laws to
enter the country as unaccompanied alien
minors they look so innocent they're not
innocent crippling loopholes in our laws
have enabled ms-13 gang members and
other criminals to infiltrate our
communities and Democrats in Congress
refused to close these loopholes
including the disgraceful practice known
as catch and release the president also
calling out Democrats who he says came
to the defense of ms-13 gang members
after he called them animals
I noticed recently where Democrats Nancy
Pelosi as an example are trying to
defend ms-13 gang members I called them
animals the other day and I was met with
rebuked they said there are people
enough people these are animals and we
have to be very very mean while a local
police commissioner sounding the alarm
on just how dangerous these gangs are to
communities we need help when we have
40% of our homicides and we had record
low homicides last year forty percent
are ms-13 related and out of that six
that they committed four of them were
butchered with machetes and buried into
graves that shallow graves that the
families can't not only identify but
can't find we need that support from the
president we have him watching our back
now he's supporting our enforcement
efforts but we can also use some funding
now from DC okay so the president
tackling this issue head-on Greg and
doubling down he was faced criticism he
said he faced rebuke for calling and
identify
specifically gang members from ms-13
calling them animals he repeated that
today and then had some evidence to back
it up
from the local authorities well
politically this is a big win for him in
this issue
Trump's stance will register for Trump
the MS and ms-13 stands for must stop
for the Democrats MS and ms-13 stands
for misunderstood and the more he splits
he shows the contrast the better it is
because the media and the Democrats they
continually with Trump they get bogged
down in language and they always lose
they're so worried about the words and
it reveals the lopsided priorities so
you got a president who's worried about
jobs terror North Korea gangs meanwhile
you have another side that's concerned
that he called gang members animals it's
like imagine your house being on fire
and your neighbors are complaining that
the fire engines are too loud that's
what that's what this is Democrats
worrying about what you call gang
members our neighbors saying hey could
your fire engines keep it down while the
house burns it's exactly that
can you imagine okay so the you know
three alarm has been sent here on Dana
for ms-13 obviously something needs to
be done about it I saw you reacting to
the statistics in terms of the number of
homicides forty percent absolutely and
the heinous nature of the crimes that
they commit well I talked to a former
prosecutor today who did a lot of these
cases especially in Maryland who said
that he thinks of ms-13 as the Mafia of
our generation and that one of the ways
that they've gone after them is like
they used to do for the mob through Rico
which is reka tearing something and
something I can't remember the exact
words but so I asked well then what laws
as the president said today like we need
Congress to do something what do you
think Congress could do that could
actually help law enforcement and he
said that he does believe that the lacs
borders is a huge problem because of the
ability to regenerate and that they are
recruiting at younger and younger ages
and that this brutality is he said it's
almost Isis like in the killing yeah in
the way and with the wood and it's and
it's ratcheting up and it's getting
worse
he also said that ms-13 was in about ten
states in two thousand five and by the
late 2000s in all 50 states
the one thing I think I think today was
important to bring attention to it I did
note that in Connell McShane when he was
doing the reporting for us today that
there was a local Democratic congressman
who was not invited to today's meeting
and I think that was a mistake I think
because he said he would have gone if he
had been invited and why not try to
co-op some of them Democrats so that you
can actually make this a bipartisan
issue and leave the people who want to
call it we want to make fun of the
president for saying animals like
they'll just have to deal with their own
politics on that side but if you really
want to solve the problem you will need
Democrats and the local congressman is
probably a good place to start that's a
really good point in terms of a take
away good good event today can be even
better for you something about it yeah I
mean the sheer numbers great point Dana
2,000 members of ms-13 on Long Island
alone and the backdrop behind the
president said secure our borders
protect our communities and one of the
participants said you can't protect our
communities until you secure our borders
and the president has that wide view
they do regenerate and the contrast you
see between the folks yelling about the
animals comment is the president wants
the rule of law enforced in laws we have
versus lawlessness he wants borders
versus open borders he believes
merit-based immigration is better than
the Russian Roulette not to use brush up
the Russian Roulette of who knows who's
coming right why they're coming what
their intentions are and Greg to your
point ms-13 is the perfect example this
president identifies opportunities to
expose the left and the insanity that
they pursue catch and release sanctuary
cities and ms-13 is that example and
everyone knows it and it's a real
problem for real people in their lives
and I think he's hit the nail on the
head on this one yes so it's a really an
unfortunate position the left finds
themself and Richard criminals but now
the proliferation has spread to all 50
states when you liken them to Isis it
seems like perfectly appropriate because
they are domestic terrorists in terms of
the crime to racketeering the murders
that they carry out so listen here's my
I might take on this so when when
President Trump me the animals come and
he complained he was being taken he was
taken out of context and he was and what
he's doing to Nancy Pelosi now is taking
her out of context completely Nancy
Pelosi's argument was a larger narrative
about what the Pres
rhetoric on immigration overall and how
this animal comets bleeds into that
larger narrative it was nothing to do
with ms-13 if you ask any Democrat on
Capitol Hill they would say yes ms-13 is
heinous they're awful and we that's what
we have laws like Rico and other laws to
make sure that gangs like that in this
country don't spread but you have to
separate ms-13 from those individuals
who from the dreamers you have to
separate ms-13 from let me finish we can
flee no she did not let me finish but
think about the mother who left
Guatemala and Nicaragua or el salvador
the three most dangerous countries on
earth when they walk 3,000 miles of all
their belonging in their children to
seek freedom and to seek the American
dream they are nowhere near what ms-13
is that that's what you're buried today
that's my point when you but you cannot
conflate you have to separate this
purposely conflate she's ms-13 is are
animals he's calling all immigrants and
what Leader Pelosi said leader Pelosi
leader because they believe Trump is
racist and so they want a miracle think
that he's racist right that listen you
just twisted a whole bunch of things to
create alternative facts here's the what
Nancy what Nancy Pelosi was trying to
say was the president's rhetoric overall
when he came down the golden staircase
on completion and murderers right the
rhetoric leads to the problem okay what
he said ms-13 all right let me respond
to that the argument that you're using
is that it really doesn't matter what
Trump said now it's what he said then
yes so that yeah which is yeah and also
one could argue what he meant back then
is exactly what he meant now he's but he
did in a sloppy way but the fact is just
that this argument cannot work you know
if somebody I didn't rob a bank but
maybe in the past I might have so he's
probably guilty if he's not guilty now
he was probably guilty then it's an
illogical argument you can't say again I
use this analogy before when you find a
hate crime and it turns out to be false
the left says well it's false here but
it could be true somewhere else it's not
it's actually deflection from actually
just admitting Trump was right and
people like Pelosi are conflate
way so unless a fusion here about public
safety and you care about people
citizens in the communities being able
to go to work to take their kids to
school why would you take the side of
people who are coming in committing
heinous crimes why are you an ms-13 why
are you denying this we can all agree
this table that he's taking Mansi Pelosi
out of contacts
I don't think so no she did not say that
she took him out of conscious a lot of
kind that he responded taking her out of
context I think that she I think that
the left has played this incorrectly
from a strategic standpoint mm-hmm
this is a community that you would think
would actually like it if the Democrats
said we understand it you're not like
them to pray come on and but we are
going to protect you by going after them
like I think that they the strategy on
all this doesn't make any sense just
admit one time the president might be
right to say I will give the president's
closing right here my argument is he is
conflating regular immigrants who are
coming here trying to seek the American
heated there but a little bit heated
over here watch this heated exchange
between the head of ice and democratic
California congresswoman Nanette
Barragan for suggesting his organization
was anti-immigrant we love to paint
immigrants as criminals that is not the
complete facts it makes me sick to my
stomach to keep hearing over and over
again painting the broad stroke in the
picture and so these are folks who are
coming here to do harm first of all no
one on this panel is anti-immigrant
we're law enforcement officers when
forcing law that you all enacted so it
sit there and say we're anti immigrants
is wrong alright Greg so people taking
offense if you say ok I'm trying but
they're not saying they're
anti-immigrant they are for upholding
the laws that are on the books how is
that anti-immigrant how is that racist
to enforce the law and ensure Public
Safety again it's an example of
conflation and it happens a lot like
we've been in this situation we will we
will
about Islamic terrorism and people
accuse me of Islamophobia thank you it's
like but I'm not actually talking about
Islam I'm talking about terrorists who
happen to be Islamic Islamic terrorism
I didn't say Islam and therefore people
go no you are Islamophobic this is the
same arguments like how dare you come
out against gangs who happen to be of a
specific minority you don't like that
minority no you are actually guilty of
doing that if you if you hear ms-13 and
hear innocent immigrants that's on you
not anybody but we do you see one of
these definitions in the dictionary of
animal is an inhuman person brutish or
beast like person named in the gym gang
member called himself an Amana a lot of
people that's your name Oh what are they
lot of athletes why it's like Isis
wrestlers they pride themselves in that
mm-hmm you know who could be more brutal
but did you notice in that hearing where
that congressman was there there was
nobody else no other congressional
member was there to question I've
literally testify in front of there's
nobody said I've said this argument over
to ever when it comes to immigration and
it comes to actually passing
comprehensive immigration reform because
our laws were made in 1984 congressman
there's some good things from 1984
though all right well we won that
argument